i think three things that made us
champions last year was one the
experience that we've been through as a
team and you know individually
collectively second i would say our
habits that we built um day in and day
out and then
our third one is to never be satisfied i
think we have those three things
together it just creates this will
hunger that keeps you going
why i stay focused is you know to stay
on my routine trying to watch a little
bit more basketball every night before i
go to sleep um you know catch up on the
game plans but then also just you know
take time to just relax and and
try to get some rest
my goal was on and off the court to
continue growing the things i've been
doing um on the court just continued to
try to repeat what we did last year um
when another championship wasn't easy
but it's something we feel we could do
again
becoming a father is it's changed my
life completely um one to know that you
know basketball isn't that serious it's
just a game so when you go home you see
your kids smiling laughing just remember
that um don't take you know anything bad
from a game anything good from a game
home i'm just you know leaving on the
court leave it at the gym and come on
relax and be with your family
to become an olympic champion the
rappers in my country is definitely one
of
my
biggest dreams growing up as a kid the
way my career started off i didn't think
it would be possible but after years of
hard work i was able to finally do it it
feels amazing